so you need a house hit the whole week
sounds like somebody's gonna have a
sweet vacay cuz I told you before my mom
is very sick I'm gonna help her move it
to assisted living well I'm here for you
and your Wi-Fi is way better than my
neighbors so I'm in it's gonna mean
taking care of Lester to walk and feed
him twice a day
give him his kidney medicine yeah got it
feed his kidneys Eleanor yeah this is
gonna be a very stressful week for me I
need to know that I can count on you I
won't let you down
I promise what's up Dom baby drop
everything you're doing
Rihanna is performing in Vegas I got
tickets we are road tripping oh I can't
I promised out house it one more day and
I have to feed this stupid dog I'm sorry
does this dog smoke blunts topless on a
yacht like a boss cuz that's how we read
ooh that's a very good point this is
floor seats in Vegas for Rihanna the
booze is free there do I really need to
keep going okay this is dinner tonight
breakfast tomorrow I have an idea
this is in case of emergency do not eat
this unless it's an emergency
well I'm ready to be a mom how's the dog
is still fat Eleonora
still fat the vet says his stomach
expanded to the size of a basketball and
that it will never straighten well
that's not my fault
how was I supposed to know you would
literally eat all of the food it
shouldn't have been an issue you were
supposed to be there but you broke your
promise as soon as it wasn't convenient
for you
and now I have a very bulbous dog well
you know what you're rude
because you didn't even ask me how the
Rihanna concert was she was very late
and a little drunk
you